همم خائبه كبيره بعد ان نجح بابي في تحقيق
ثلاثه اهداف خيل الفرنسيين ان الكاس سيكون
في متناول ايديهم للمره الثالثه بعد فوز
العام 98 ثم ال 2018 لكن ذلك لم يحصل انقل
خيبه الناس على الارض هنا بدايه
هل هناك همم
هذا املنا بفعل هزيمه فرنسا ميرسي همم
حتى لو كنا نامل انهم سيربحون هذه الليله
همم دبقيقه
[موسيقى]
بالفوز اعرب عبروا عن خيبه كبيره اذا
اماجرا وما كان يعتقد انه سيكون احتفالا
ضخما تحول الى
الى خيبه كبيره ومجموعات متفرقه من الناس
يقفون يعبرون عن خيبهم
واشاره ميسون الى انها الذين كانوا
يتجمعون هنا باعداد ضخمه في محيط قوس
النصر وكانوا يستعدون في النزول للنزول
بموكب كبير من قوس النصر نحو الشانزليزيه
وباصولا الى ساحه الكونكورد تفرقوا في
الشوارع المحيطه بالجدات الواقعه الى جانب
قوس النصر خيبه كبيره وحزن يلف كل الذين
كانوا ينتظرون على مدى اكثر من ساعتين
ونصف